the Golden Globes after after party is
right here on E.T who needs sleep
welcome to Entertainment Tonight it had
everything we love about awards show yes
it did it had laughter tears it had
awkwardness but one thing's for sure the
Globes were turned with Peak star power
[Music]
mother is in the building
to you to you
I'm still getting used to these types of
things Rihanna Brad Selena with her date
nine-year-old sister Gracie and this
Trio of men we love but it was Cecil B
Demille Award winner Eddie Murphy who
got the stand you know pay your taxes
mind your business
and keep Will Smith's wife's name
you closed with a bag I love Chris and
will and it's all love or what does it
mean to receive this award tonight and
is I mean because you're not career is
not over well actually my career is over
did you at the end no this is nice it's
nice to to get to get some recognition
and and get a nice award what do people
come up to you and quote the most people
come up and say sexual chocolate
Hercules for Hercules Hercules the
strangest thing a person's ever said to
me hey man you still got that laugh
and I said yeah he said
was it real or was that computers
my mission was to take the invisible the
unloved and make them the heroes Brian
Murphy took home the Carol Burnett award
and gave a shout out to Jennifer
Coolidge who won best supporting actress
in a limited series for the White Lotus
Jennifer danced on the red carpet at the
after party and I raised a glass is
there any chance at all that you can
come back again these gays they're
trying to murder me I don't think so I
don't know I mean he might you know you
never know would you do it yes of course
if you could figure out but I don't know
you know there's chocolate I don't know
how he would do that but
but I'm game you've had just this
Resurgence of a career I kind of blame
the the this generation this new
generation for sort of bringing me back
I feel like Ariana Grande put me under
video have you ever gone out with
someone that had no teeth at all that
changed a lot for me over at sort of
overnight I don't know maybe people are
just like she's still alive
you do see me in this dress tomorrow all
right
I ain't saw it I'm not saying anything
One winner missing from the night Kevin
Costner I'm just so sorry that I can't
be there freeways flooded out we find
ourselves on the wrong side of the town
and we couldn't get back last night the
Yellowstone star won best actor in a
drama series but was forced to hunker
down at his Santa Barbara Ranch after
torrential rain caused flooding property
damage and mass evacuations in the area
this week
presenter Regina Hall awkwardly accepted
the award on his behalf Kevin Costner
he's so much wanted to
I always like how they write this the
unprecedented weather and flooding he
has the shelter in place in Santa
Barbara Jesus let's pray everyone no no
no this is true
also true you'd be hard-pressed to find
a bigger Yellowstone fan than Henry
Winkler
first time you know in Ron Howard's
first movie he was an extra in night
shift
and now he is the king of the world
Cole Hauser is here on the red carpet
oh my God is he amazing or what rip is
one of the coolest guys on television
ever I'm a big fan of his as well so it
would be an honor to meet him Cole
Hauser walked the carpet with his wife
Cynthia Daniel and drop this news we'll
get two more seasons of Yellowstone I
can tell you there'll be six and
there'll be a seven so that's all I can
tell you
you can't stop Yellowstone and first
time winner Austin Butler can't shake
the King this is like a Monumental
moment for you do you feel it I I do I
think so the Presley family thank you
guys it was so incredible and so spot on
he nailed it I don't think I sound like
him still
listen to the California Native with E.T
in 2013. that's what I'm hoping for
be great too not only did you pay homage
to Elvis in your speech you did shout
out Denzel Washington thank you for your
generosity in in championing me when you
did not have to doing this play that I
did with Denzel on Broadway like that
was the thing that changed my career he
took it out of the kindness of his heart
to call Basin I'm so grateful to him
congratulations man Austin was loving up
girlfriend Kaia Gerber all night leaving
an after party at 3 30 a.m with her
asleep on his shoulder
your husband using his phone to record
everything tonight he's a sweetie
hard and and he he believed in this
moment he he he just I think maybe he
manifested in 1994. I stood on this
stage and accepted
the Golden Globe for What's Love Got to
Do with it thank you thank you thank you
God it's almost 30 years later I know
that's that's pretty amazing that that
just shows you the you know the journey
Angela screamed for this lady's Journey
Michelle yo winning after waiting 40
years and no one was gonna play her off
the stage all that was shut up please
I didn't realize I was so naughty I was
like no I can beat you up okay and you
know I can do it I think you could have
impressed your newest director James
Cameron or Avatar you're gonna join the
franchise correct oh yes three has been
shot
four is partly shot
everybody's told me that there's new
people joining that I'm going to lose my
mind about oh my God stop it okay but
our praise for a fellow winner and
co-star kihui Kwan won't stop after his
emotional full circle moment 38 years
you've been dreaming of being here at
the Golden Globes yeah that's
true so to get used
it feels incredible I started my career
as a child actor in Indiana Jones and
the Temple of Doom okay great key lovely
oh my God I am so happy to see Steven
Spielberg here tonight Stephen thanks
thank you that gave me the greatest joy
because that man gave me my first
opportunity I gotta Standing Ovation
from Steven Spielberg
last night's Best Director winner who
also worked with key in The Goonies
revealed his Indie casting could have
gone another way his cousin was rooting
for the part and we saw Keith sitting in
the waiting room and said can we bring
this younger kid in to meet me
and that's sort of how it happened in
the universe
he may have beat out Brad Pitt but he
still had the best night showing off a
short haircut and a new smile he got his
chipped tooth fixed from last summer
Pitt was the globe's MVP yep the stars
are just like us obsessed with Brad
I love you I think they got my name
wrong
yeah it's Mrs Pitt
inside the show our eyewitness saw Brad
sipping on water since he's sober and
cracking jokes at his table the ladies
next to him that's his manager on the
other side his Babylon co-star Margot
Robbie who was working on a remake of
Brad's film Ocean's 11 co-starring Ryan
Gosling hopefully we're moving ahead
doing that this year Brad's Glory also
got the cast of Abbott Elementary all
flustered during their best comedy
series win hey Brett Pitt
um
I'm gonna pull it together where you
headed next where am I to the after
party today to rub shoulders with Brad
Pitt I'm like what are you doing outside
Brad Pitt you should be in a famous man
uh location I think we're just gonna
have a little fun at the after party and
then probably go home because we have
these early as call times I may not see
it's a lot or drink a lot but I'm gonna
have a good time Quincy get up here
up his promised Abbott's Creator and
star Quinta Brunson hit the party scene
holding her two statuettes she also won
best performance by an actress in a TV
series musical or comedy okay let me get
past my family text messaging uh I
couldn't get back in my phone all the
text messages were going bananas and you
were like stop please I'm trying to I
really was trying to read the speech but
Tyler James Tyler got a standing ovation
from Eddie Murphy for his first Golden
Globe win the first time I was here I
was 13 when Everybody Hates Chris was
nominated look at me man I'm killing I'm
very proud of this cast
you know especially Tyler here ET spoke
to that Dapper little dude alongside
Chris Rock leading up to that 2006 red
carpet the Golden Globes have movie
stars and TVs
looking forward to it and go into the
Golden Globes while Cheryl Lee Ralph
lost to Ozarks Julia Garner she told us
being nominated is a win in itself and
today a season three was confirmed I am
so thankful to be here I am so thankful
to have my name called as one of the
best now in the world now despite all
the star power it seems Hollywood might
not love a comeback after a one-year
Hiatus boycotts and controversy for a
lack of diversity it could be the lowest
rated globes in almost 30 years with
early numbers saying less than 5.4
million tuned in I am your host Gerard
Carl Michael and I'll tell you why I'm
here I'm here because I'm black
look how much are they paying you five
hundred thousand dollars boy if you
don't put on a good suit and take some
white people money host Gerard
Carmichael Came Out Swinging and gave us
one of the most cringe-worthy moments of
the night with this backstage I found
these
uh three Golden Globe awards that Tom
Cruise returned
I think maybe we take these three things
and exchange them for the safe return of
Shelley miskovich
the joke about scientology leader David
miscavige's wife landed with Leah Remini
who took to Twitter to add where is
Shelley but The Show Must Go On
from Top Gun Maverick please welcome
Glenn Powell and Jay Ellis y'all have
fun I know listen your brethren are
running around here acting up already
they're not meant for this environment
you can put them in in nice clothes but
they're not going to behave we're gonna
have a good time tonight the boys of
Maverick lost out to Steven Spielberg's
the fablemans for best Motion Picture
drama and victory was twice as nice for
Stephen who also took home Best Director
you thanked us you said you wouldn't be
here without E.T and well we understand
yeah you heard that tonight didn't you
when you uh originated your brand you
came on the ET set in 1981 and you were
there with your little mics with the E.T
on it and I immediately wanted to call
my lawyers to sue you
I thought oh my God they took my title
and look all these years later we've
managed to co-exist people
[Music]